la tabla muestra valores seleccionados
de la función diferenciable efe ok
podemos usar el teorema del valor medio
para decir que existe un valor ce tal
que f prima de sem es igual a 5 y que se
esté entre 4 y 6
de ser así escribe una justificación
bueno para usar el teorema del valor
medio necesitamos una función que sea
diferenciable en el intervalo abierto y
continua en el intervalo cerrado así que
parece que cumplimos esta condición si
nos dicen que tenemos una función
diferenciable en un intervalo entonces
definitivamente tendremos una función
continua en el mismo intervalo y como
nos dicen de manera general que tenemos
una función diferenciable efe podemos
suponer que es diferenciable para
cualquier intervalo
bueno después de esto podemos decir si
ya cumplimos esta condición y si nos
fijamos en la pendiente de la recta
secante
entre los puntos 4,4 y 6,6 entonces debe
existir al menos un punto entre 4 y 6
tal que la derivada evaluada en ese
punto sea igual a la pendiente de esta
recta secante por lo tanto calculemos la
pendiente de la recta secante entre
estos dos puntos entre el punto 4
efe de 4 y 6 efe de 6 y si es igual a 5
entonces podemos utilizar el teorema del
valor medio si no es igual a 5 entonces
no podremos aplicarlo
así que hagámoslo cuánto es efe de 6 -
efe de 4 esto dividido
/ 64
bueno estos datos nos los dan en la
tabla
efe de 6 a 7 me va a quedar
7 - efe de 4 que es 3 - 3 ok esto entre
6 menos 4 lo cual es 2 y esto es 4 entre
2 lo cual es 2 y como todos no es igual
a 5 entonces no podemos aplicar el
teorema del valor medio déjame
escribirlo como 2 no es igual a 5
entonces no podemos aplicar el teorema
del valor medio y es más déjame poner
signos de admiración para hacer más
énfasis muy bien ahora
respondamos la segunda pregunta podemos
usar el teorema del valor medio otra vez
para decir que la ecuación f prima de x
igual a menos 1 tiene una solución en el
intervalo 0 menor que x menor que 2
de ser así escribe una justificación
bueno
trabajemos esta pregunta si tomamos la
pendiente de la recta secante ésta va a
ser
efe de 2
- efe de 0
ok entre 20
2 - 0 y esto va a ser igual a bueno efe
de 2 es menos 2
entonces me quedara - 2 - efe de 0 que
es 0
- 0 entre 2 y esto es lo mismo que menos
2 - 0 - 2 entre 2 es menos 1
y está muy bien además sabemos que se
cumplen las condiciones de continuidad y
diferencia habilidad así que
escribiremos lo siguiente como f es
diferenciable en general
efe será diferenciable y continua en el
intervalo cerrado de 0 a 2 en el
intervalo cerrado recuerda la función
debe de ser diferenciable solo en el
intervalo abierto pero creo que es mejor
que tengamos a la función diferenciable
en el intervalo cerrado porque
necesitamos que la función sea continua
en el intervalo cerrado y después pondré
el teorema del valor medio nos dice que
existe una equis en el intervalo abierto
de 0 a 2
efe prima de x es decir la tasa de
cambio promedio o la pendiente de la
recta secante esto es igual a menos 1
así que podemos escribir que si si
podemos utilizar este teorema
y justo esta es mi justificación podemos
ver que la pendiente de la recta secante
o la tasa de cambio promedio es igual a
menos 1 y como efes diferenciable en
general
efe será diferenciable y continua en el
intervalo cerrado 0.2 el teorema del
valor medio nos dice que existe una
equis en el intervalo abierto de 0.2 tal
que f prima de x es igual a menos 1
y hemos terminado nos vemos pronto en
otro vídeo